welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in spider-man far from home is now
available in digital HD allowing the
obsessives like me a chance to truly go
frame-by-frame through this film and 4k
to savor every precious second of Tom
Holland Peter Parker's final hours in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe were sony
snatches him away from us one of the
craziest easter eggs I've been catching
to my rewatch is concerned Mysterio not
just Quentin Beck but the true Mysterio
since let's be honest it was a team
effort went in back along with former
Stark Industries cohort William Ginter
Eva
dude ermine Janus Victoria all these
folks shared out an impressive ability
of blending in and hiding in plain sight
like these villains were under Peter
Parker's nose the whole time
infiltrating his summer vacation and
coming striking distance of ruining his
life hell you could even say that by the
post-credits scene T Mysterio truly did
win in that regard
along with infinity war far from home is
the only MCU film to end in utter
catastrophe for the hero
I mean sure Ragnarok ended with an
entire home playing agane destroyed like
a positive note now one of the deleted
scenes from the far from home extended
cut showed t Mysterio in their London
disguises has Beck made a phony phone
call to Nick Fury from their bunker
there's larious each team members
wearing goofy costumes as tourists
bicyclists and like the costumes they
wore in that Prague bar it reminds us
that these conspirators are freakin
master of disguises and if you were
looking carefully they're hiding all
over this movie so in this episode I'm
gonna break down every team Mysterio
sighting that we overlooked the first
time we watched far from home okay the
first hidden sighting shows up in Venice
long before Peter shakes hands with
Quentin Beck even before Peter fights
what he thinks is the water elemental
alongside what he thinks is Mysterio
what he thinks what he thinks everything
in this movie is lies anyway when Peter
heads off to buy a necklace for MJ in
the background on the left there is a
tourist wearing a hat and Hawaiian shirt
when he turns around there's a beard
there and a couple seconds before the
camera cuts away it is totally Quentin
Beck creeping on Peter who the director
John Watts put Jake Gyllenhaal in
costume snuck him into the background in
this scene and whether or not you knew
about this this is the first of many t
Mysterio sightings in the film but
before we continue thank you to Ben
Sarah watches for sponsoring this
episode we decided to partner with Vince
arrow because we figured hey if I'm
gonna be wildly gesticulating my arm at
the camera so damn much might as well
slip something classy
on it so these are the generic or
minimalist cookie cutter designs and
Sarah are crafted to set you apart
rather than conform you'll get noticed
and complimented as opposed to forgotten
or screamed at for getting the theory
wrong a piece like this will instill a
sense of rebellious confidence so much
so that you'll call a watch a piece this
baby is gunmetal three one six cell
surgical grade stainless steel and a top
grain walnut Italian leather strap it's
got sapphire coated crystal scratch
resistant glass face it's not a web
shooter but it still feels real good on
your wrist then sarah provides the same
look and feel of luxury watches ten
times the price of theirs and they offer
free worldwide shipping so check them
out yourself just click on the link in
the description below for a special
offer of 15% off with the promo code
rockstars okay back to t Mysterio
creeping around on Peter throughout far
from home there are even more sightings
and possible sightings throughout the
streets and canals of Venice
after Peter buys a necklace he and MJ
stroll along the canal and briefly
passing them giving them a look oh that
scooter man Guth's he's the storyteller
of t Mysterio he crafted all the
narratives of x-pac story and each
elemental attack and looking closely the
background there might be some site into
the rest of the team like as Peter
leaves the shop there's a blonde woman
at a fish counter on the left side of
frame looks a bit like the blonde in T
Mysterio credited only as the seamstress
and right before gutes shows up on the
steps in the distant background there's
a bald man who might be William guitar
eva though i guess if it's this close to
the show he would probably be tucked
away in a drone control booth somewhere
nearby and shortly after that there's a
woman with dark hair passing behind
peter and MJ looks a bit like janice the
team member who notified the others that
tony stark planned to bequeath edith to
peter parker the fact that beck and some
of the others were stalking peter before
the first water elemental attack tells
us that it wasn't Peters interference
that put him on a collision course of T
Mysterio this wasn't an accident at all
this team pre-selected Venice as an
attack location because they knew that
Peter Parker would be there and would
receive Tony starts eated classes which
of course is a real thing they were
after in fact it's possible that T
Mysterio was even more involved in
Peters whole summer plans think about it
we never quite know why Peter and his
friends are going on this euro trip now
later on the chaperones joke that it's
supposed to be a science trip but at no
point do any of them do
sciency they're seeing the sites like
museums festivals opera a gondola ride
tour buses and on every leg of this
journey their plans are suddenly changed
but really ways to redirect Peter to
bring him closer to the action Peter and
Ned thought it was Nick Fury hijacking
their summer vacation really this whole
operation was orchestrated by Mysterio
so what if the whole trip from the
beginning was an offer by this team
designed to extract Peter out of his
safe home neighborhood and expose him on
foreign soil to make him more vulnerable
so they could steal the Edith glasses if
these folks can trick millions of people
with holo projected monsters attacking
major world cities they can definitely
rig up a dozen international flights and
itineraries and the team just so
effortlessly slips in and out of these
travel scenarios
kudamon becomes the group's tour bus
driver in London and later he abandons
them on a Tower Bridge and if you look
closely can be seen leaning against an
archway near the Tower of London as the
kids run past him with this level of
control it is amazing that any of the
kids from Midtown high made it out of
this alive and there's one final new
detail I spotted in the rewatch that
tells us just how close team Mysterio
got to completely off Ian Peter Parker
the moment Quentin Beck appears to be
dying and he appears to hand back the
Edith glasses course this is just a
projection the way he's holding those
glasses matches the way that the real
Mysterio hidden beside Peter is aiming a
gun at his head Peter catches and
deflects the shot at the last second we
don't even have time to breathe a sigh
of relief it happened so fast but this
is one of the many moments we nearly saw
Peter Parker's blood spilled all over
the screen so to me Mysterio not just
Quentin back but the whole team is the
most effective MCU villain besides
Thanos really no one else so
devastatingly deceives the hero and
deceives several others including Nick
Fury and Maria hill not just to scroll
versions of these characters but
presumably the real Nick Fury because
that Nick Fury thought it would be safe
to leave Peter and Talos with Quentin
Beck in post credits scene when Talos
reported to Nick Fury that everything
was okay presumably fury must have
thought everything would have been okay
- so Mysterio infiltrated everyone's
defenses they messed him up real bad and
they ruined Peter Parker's life and
still there's also enough evidence to
suggest that Quentin Beck might not even
be dead go check out that video when you
can but how do you think Mysterio
pairs to other MCU villains comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Avis and
subscribe to new rock stars for the
breakdowns of theories for everything
Marvel thank you for joining me and just
so you know Philip and I are also
similarly locked in a battle of control
over Edythe sunglasses many will die
[Music]